[Music]
a tesla driver was spotted watching porn
while stuck in traffic why wouldn't you
that's the benefit that's why you get a
tesla yeah yeah
why
i think that's like the uh american way
but i think the original way is that
tesla yeah like we say nike but it's the
night view but it's actually mike
[Laughter]
what a lot bro
this is a that's a really good that's a
really good shot that's a really good
show what is that those are legs just
legs up baby just open wait what the
[ __ ] is it a crane shot like i knew it
would be the most regular porn
semi truck wait something adventurous
you can watch shows while you're driving
because i thought that there was like a
safety thing where you can only watch it
parked that's what i thought too
i have this [ __ ] like a [ __ ] man
i have one but like i can't watch [ __ ]
you gotta get that gotta get that
brother's firmware on your was he beaten
off while he was watching i you know
that's a great i don't understand people
that just watch porn and they don't beat
off at the same time yeah is that
creepier actually i have to be
completely honest with you you research
it let me finish let me think can we
just fill in the blanks for you
yeah can we assume everything i'm not
going to say anything
he's the kind of guy that has a
clipboard and he watches porn and he
writes everything wrong about it that's
an interesting judgment of me
no but you watch porno without touching
yourself so anytime i uh anytime i'm
driving for a long distance and i just
you have the message i started getting
sleepy do you want me to stay when i
when i get where are we going with this
low key that's a fire strategy
this is what i'm saying i do all the
slapping i'll do hidden i'll play music
crazy i'll put down the window and what
it's a really long drive and i can't do
anything else to keep myself awake i'll
[ __ ] put porn on on my phone and then
have the audio go on and you don't even
have to watch it i swear to god if
you're just
you bust nuts from listening to it dude
you don't even touch it
nobody actually said anything about
bustling
like this you drive like this
[Laughter]
aussie three and nine
don't judge me he's the one that's
[ __ ] busting it hey
is weirder than busting nuts on audio
all right
cause i was following his logic and i
was like okay that makes sense i can
make sense but then as soon as you said
nine and tell them that that doesn't
make sense i'll take it i'll take it off
that's your last resort to stay awake i
love that i'm gonna try driving like
this tonight then psychologically like
even even if you're not watching it
maybe just the the taboo concept of like
getting caught or something you just
wake the [ __ ] up so this guy was just
sleepy while he was driving
for you it's the it's the uh
forbiddenness like you're just trying to
stay awake also it sounds funny as [ __ ]
how do you no i was just saying as
someone that falls asleep when they
drive like after a long wait what the
[ __ ] yeah sometimes you just fall asleep
it's just two years you'll get tired
when you take the road oh i have a tesla
so i just gotta just fall asleep i just
knock out
my point is when you get sleepy and
you're trying to slap your face you're
trying to stick your head out the
[ __ ] window i think that probably
does work it hella works like because
falling asleep one is like my biggest
pet peeve
for my own life of driving because
you're putting yourself in your
dangerous position and other people yeah
and it's just the worst [ __ ] feeling
so i i tried to find anything there's
this whole thing where i started like uh
pinching the inside of your thigh i've
done that yeah right so so you just do a
bunch of things to try and stay with any
gummy bears that's what the second you
[ __ ] put on something like porn
guaranteed you're you're well i don't
know what to find though because i can
never find like the one right off the
bat is it you just play whatever's just
you just put whatever you're not really
watching it because you have to you're
watching it bro yeah because your hands
are at 10 at night
but your eyes your eyes are your eyes
are at six have you ever have you ever
jacked off and then trained
or there's some that doesn't make that's
not science don't let your mom watch
this episode dude i feel like she's
gonna find it
or have you ever jacked off and then you
train that's just the name of the video
brandon jacks off then trains
and then her punches are like i told
that too like don't don't [ __ ] or or
come before a fight like stay like who's
your leg is that a myth or what is that
who ruins your life that's what they say
that's what they call that yeah it ruins
your leg yeah right is that what you say
like a long-term fight it does you can i
mean you could feel a difference like
long-term sparring sessions i guess you
could feel a difference because i'll say
this well you ever have an intense
lovemaking session and your legs are
just like wobbly they're just so yeah
they're wobbly bart has it he doesn't
know what they're talking about
it feels like lava yeah they're all
wobbly amen to that brother come on
brother
and then the next day when you train you
kind of
kind of suck a little did your dad ever
hold mitts and he's like no you jacked
off
freddie you [ __ ] it again dude god damn
i'm here with those jack off legs oh my
god
guess i'm coming your fight you better
be filled up by the time you fight son i
don't have aggression after i come it's
difficult
because like yeah you only start judging
yourself they don't check come levels
like when you go if i start sparring and
[ __ ] i'm all like bro can we just hug
and [ __ ] and like go chill well they say
like you release your testosterone or
something it's just i like the way you
like bob and weave all those [ __ ] see
what are they there
all those like verbal bobbin
yeah he doesn't want to answer any of
the questions good for you swerving it
up
when you're in camp is it like a
personal rule no jacking off
all right you don't have to answer that
this is for fun just in case your mom's
watching well you can answer it if you
would like to
it's up to you what is it
who is scarier to find this video your
mom and your dad like who would be like
worse to hear it from she's probably my
dad 100.
but my dad probably like what the hell
my mom like she's like
i feel like my mom like we could talk
about anything oh okay but like my dad
is like i don't know if it's just my dad
or just the asian thing i don't know
more strict yeah
damn he's like there's too much estrogen
in that room
you're going in that roof you're going
to ruin your testosterone and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i actually do remember
i actually do remember
not jacking off and watching porn
wait what yeah it was because 10 minutes
later yeah
because i was i was judging i was
judging people i was like who's the
[ __ ] that watches porn and
doesn't do [ __ ] to their dick right and
i was like oh that's me i'm guilty
because i read a study that um men who
are constantly looking at like naked
women and all that it actually boosts
your testosterone so i was like okay how
do i boost my natural testosterone let
me look at the most sexual things that i
can see which is porn right and then as
soon as i'm like all [ __ ] horny as
[ __ ] i start working out oh yeah does it
work yeah did you feel like you naked as
you're working out you pump an iron with
your penis or what's going on it got me
excited and they got me motivated and i
was using all that horny energy to
[ __ ] lift and [ __ ] it was yeah it's
different right they played porn at
planet finish now yeah
they put on the tv now i don't know how
it makes sense if it's true science but
all i know is that whatever got me hyped
whether it's like anger horny whatever
it helps me lift because i'm just i'm
just on a higher emotional state did you
get blue balls yeah after you finished
lifting did you have to go back and
finish the hell yeah i did
hell yeah i [ __ ] took a shower
[ __ ] beat off and took a nap smoked a
cigarette
with his cigarette like he just
accomplished after working out he just
pulled a deep drag
that's a good workout dude obviously
it's a it's a whole
like [ __ ] ceremony right so it's too
much dang work it's just easier to wake
up and [ __ ] like lift i don't know
ceremony is that the best pre-workout
you would say i don't think it was the
best it was pretty good this barbell
brigade pre-workout yeah barbell's 10
out of 10. jacking off or actually
watching poor before you work out
probably like a six out of ten right i
don't know
i think a good warm-up and coffee does
the job too you know yeah you're gonna
watch 20 minutes of porn i got a [ __ ]
so i'm not working
horny and then go to the gym with a
[ __ ] raging boner no don't do that
dude
but do that but imagine going to a
boxing gym everyone be like i'm not
training with you right now get your ass
out you've got a weird energy today bro
right every time it goes back in the
corner
they put a phone right in front of his
eyes
the vr
oh my god those [ __ ] shorts are thin
as [ __ ] too oh they're all silky and
[ __ ] damn you pitching a tent bro
i'm so sorry dude i'm sorry dude
[Music]
you